des précipitations records ce week-end
sur trappes et la plaine de Versailles
il a plu en trois jours ce qu'il tombe
habituellement en un mois de la pluie
toujours de la pluie et les seuls
qu'elle n'a pas effrayé ce sont les
nageurs le meeting national organisé par
le club de Saint-Quentin lundi de
Pentecôte a été maintenu les maillots de
bain se mêlent au coupe-vent sa pénalise
parce qu'ils sont pas mis dans les
meilleures conditions par rapport à la
compétition mais je peux vous promettre
une fois qu'ils sont dans l'eau l'eau à
la température
sur le reste des manifestations en plein
air il n'y avait pas foule l'événement
vers les Yvelines n'a pas démarré sur
les chapeaux de roue pour la randonnée
équestre seule trois personnes sur les 7
inscrits ont osé braver le mauvais temps
la randonnée vélo n'a attiré de son côté
que 50 participants sur les 100 attendus
au niveau du Golf National fréquentation
amoindri également on ne comptabilisé
sur les trois jours que 448 parcours
contre 1149 l'année dernière une baisse
qui persiste depuis le début de l'année
le beau temps commence à se faire
sérieusement désirer
dans les prochains jours
ça devrait être un petit peu plus sec
que ce qu'on a connu au cours du
week-end de la Pentecôte mais il existe
encore un risque de précipitation plutôt
sous forme d'averses dans les jours qui
viennent avec des températures qui
restent en dessous des normales de
saison après ce week-end froid et
pluvieux on peut espérer des
températures plus douces jusqu'à 19
degrés croisons les doigts
un peu saccadé mais